this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week since so many players have returned
to the trenches Jonathan is taking
another look at some of the World War
One era Weaponry of Battlefield 1. right
well they've done it to me again we've
got a semi-cursed gun it's not too bad I
could sort of picture some incredibly
flamboyant Russian officer having some
gold-plated modified 1895 sniper rifle
make sure to subscribe and check out our
previous episode on Battlefield 1 where
Jonathan showcased the tiny caliber
pistol from the Royal armories
collection and if you like this kind of
content we've got a brand new season of
loader airing on the channel right now
new episodes will launch every Sunday
including deep dives into sniper rifles
the AK-47 and the scar so make sure to
keep your eyes peeled for those right
let's take a look at some more of the
weapons of Battlefield 1.
this is something I don't remember from
playing Battlefield one I did put in
quite a few hours to this game there are
cutouts on the frame of this 1911 pistol
behind the trigger and that's to allow
shorter fingers essentially to wrap
around and reach the shorter trigger
that this doesn't have so what am I
talking about well this is built as a
1911 M1911 it's actually a weird
mishmash but we've got the extended
safety beaver tail of an A1 by the look
of it we have the finger cut out Groove
things in the frame of an A1 I think I'm
right saying everything else on this is
original 1911 from 1911 I.E what you'd
have in the first world war you wouldn't
have the Cutaway bits back then because
they are features of the 1911 A1 which
came in in 1926 if I remember correctly
something else I don't remember from
playing this game the rear sight on the
1911 is
really really wide sights on pistols in
this era were not great not by modern
standards they were designed to be low
profile and not snag on uniform or
whatever this is very very broad I have
to assume that's similar to the enlarged
rear sights on games like Call of Duty
and probably Battlefield as well
thinking about it where you're trying to
give the player a wider field of view
and because you don't have to line up
your frontal area site nothing's really
lost except for people like me picking
Nets
sudden surprise stopped 1911 pistol here
so I had to just run and grab the
closest thing we have
which is this piece
it's not the same it's not the same as
what's on screen what's on screen is
very much inspired by the John Dillinger
pistol so it has a Tommy gun shaped
front grip ours is an IRA capture design
intended to be fully automatic with a
detachable stock it's pretty rickety
extended magazine and they did not go
despite the RAS fondness for the Tommy
Gun they did not go for the tommy gun
shaped front grip it's more of a broom
handle it's a bit of a mess to be honest
now both of the neither of these fits
the first world war setting this is
1970s John Dillinger was around in the
20s after the war of course so to my
knowledge nothing like this existed in
the first World War
uh perhaps an obvious inclusion for a
first world war set game that's trying
to up the ante and include as many semi
and full automatic weapons as it could
this is the howl this thing the howl is
a genuine self-loading only
adaptation of the smle for the first
world war did not see any significant
use that I'm aware of it's bizarre it's
you know the word steampunk gets bandied
around with a lot of these guns uh you
know they've done a great job with this
it's got an extended trench magazine
which our our version does not the only
criticism I would have I think
um the way it appears anyway is the
bipod from memory from our two examples
that we have here they don't have a
bipod I'm not aware of this of the of
this having a bipod I could be wrong on
that
foreign
the operation of this is okay except the
magazine change we've got a major fudge
on the mag change if you're trying to do
a MAG change on this we don't see the
player character press the magazine
catch as far as I can tell you can't
really use your firing thing where you
can't at all use your firing finger to
press that magazine catch up this
magazine was not designed to be easily
replaced despite the early intent of the
Metford to have a spare magazine for
emergencies to swap it was never meant
to be a quick change magazine so it's
hard to reach and hard to press the best
at times this one as I say is even
harder and because of the hand guard
here you can't you know you can't sort
of brace it and get in and press
efficiently to remove the magazine you
certainly can't do it with your support
cam either so you're holding it like
this braced into your your arm pit come
up like this you can try to you can just
about maybe get your thumb in but I
can't get it to release
and then bearing in mind the extended
mag would seriously getting you your way
anyway you'd have to come in like this
press up I won't do it because the mag
might fall out press up hard on the
catch and maybe let it fall and then you
put on a spare magazine but this is not
designed for tactical magazine changes
it would have been topped up with
stripper clips
foreign
the mg08 slash 18 which is immensely
heavy so I'm going to rest it on the
chair here and hope it doesn't crush me
and parts you don't wish to be crushed
in now I put the belt box on here
complete with crank so there is an
animation for cranking the belt box
which is nice I won't try to feed this
into this gun because this mgo8 belt is
very frayed and fragile and I don't want
to damage it any further but when you
load this thing it's not as
straightforward as the game would imply
you cannot flip up the top cover like a
modern machine gun slap the belt in
place and slap the top cover down you
have to it's a maxim feed it in with a
starter tab pull it physically across to
the left while you [ __ ] the gun twice
that's the standard drill for all
Maximum pattern machine guns and we're
not doing that we're not doing that here
and you could not do it from a standing
position you'd have to put this thing on
the deck and either have a have an
assistant Gunner to pull the belt across
for you or realistically with a weapon
like this that's modified for one man to
use you could absolutely do it I would
absolutely do it on your own but not
from a standing position it would be
physically impossible to do that this
one has aircraft sights or anti-aircraft
salts installed on it this was a light
machine gun gun from memory I'm not
aware of an aircraft adaptation for it
however if these are anti-aircraft sites
which seems Seems more likely actually
Zen maybe I don't remember seeing them
but hey there's every chance that they
are correct
foreign
istic as in they weren't actually in use
in the first world war but they did
exist guns in this game the Winchester
1907 probably my favorite just because
it's I don't know it feels like the most
capable thing that you could have 1907
of course when it's once introduced but
as you can see from the from the reload
which is Faithfully done you've got a
magazine catch here press with the thumb
pull out with the same hand
the animation seems to have the thumb go
for the catch again you don't need to do
that just like we don't with an AR or
something you just plug it back into
place cocking handle or charging handle
at the front uh produce C operated it's
very stiff
it just I think just the look of it is
great it's short it's light it's handy
the because the wooden four end on the
version here has a full grip on it now
they're worse than 1920s modifications
to these for law enforcement so before
the foregrip there is plausible but
wouldn't have been done until
Prohibition in the states the weird
Leather Pouch on the front that's
strapped over the barrel I yeah don't
know that seems like it'll get in the
way worth saying there's a lot of detail
in these in these gun models you know
you can see the the little extractor
there on the face of the bolts it's a
really nice attention to detail on
basically all the guns in this game
foreign
[Applause]
rifle but not any old Springfield 1903
Rifle this is fitted with the
euphemistically called the experimental
device one of the well relatively rare
instance in this game of a name not
being included this is the Pederson
device invented by John Patterson the
idea was that you could carry the
blowback operated so semi-automatic
pistol it's a it's a semi-automatic
pistol you shove up the back of your gun
of your rifle I should say so that whole
device would come out the back and be
carried in a metal tin and then you'd
have the magazines inserted as we're
going to see in a moment the great big
blowback slide effectively on top of it
it's a very distinctive look to the gun
with that little magazine sticking out
the side uh keep an eye out for the cut
out in the receiver of the rifle pull
point of removing this device was that
you could have the ordinary rifle bolt
installed for long range accurate not
accurate and firing and then when it
when the time came to go over the top
you would swap out the two bolts
effectively and go semi Go full semi uh
automatic so it needed a cutout in in
the receiver to eject the spent
cartridge cases that did not adversely
affect the operation of the rifle with
the ordinary bolt installed suppose it
might let a bit more mud and water in or
something but probably not a huge issue
so you can always spot a converted 1903
for the cutout in the left side of the
receiver
so that's a a very nice touch indeed
we're actually we're not treating this
as a separate weapon that just happens
to look like a Springfield this thing is
actually being converted before our eyes
exactly as it was intended to be into a
semi-automatic pistol caliber carbine
rifle thing they've reduced the visible
recoil of this thing firing this low
powered cartridge which is good if
anything I think they haven't reduced it
enough if you watch the the sea and
Arsenal shooting video of this the the
weapon recoils very very little it's a
very heavy steel and walnut rifle with a
very weak cartridge relative to that so
it barely moved so it's a beefier
cartridge than 22 but
um a much heavier gun so it's kind of
ends up being much the same
my old friend the martini Henry grew up
watching Zulu as I think every one of my
generation did intrigued by this kind of
middling technology so the rifle
depicted is specifically a mark IV
Martini Henry you can spot those due to
the hump here so as far as how the right
how well the rifle is depicted now that
we know it's a mark IV it's pretty good
looks too short to me proportions
aren't right I think the butt length is
right but everything forward of the of
the action body or receiver yeah I can't
quite put my finger on that but I don't
think it's an optical illusion I think
the rifle is too short
something I've noticed I think in the
game overall but it's especially
noticeable with the great honking
cartridge that the martini fires is the
relative size of the cartridge to not so
much the weapon but to the hand of the
operator the Handler they either have
huge hands or the cartridges depicted as
too small so the hands seem to be in
scale with the rifle somehow but not
really with the cartridge by this time
they've been replaced from 1894 onwards
for machine guns because the martini was
basically out of use by this point they
were made out of as normal cartridge
cases so if you were using your fantasy
retro Martini Henry in the first world
war you wouldn't have the potential
issue of the very weak
rolled up brass cartridges I'm not even
going to complain about it being in
Battlefield 1 because it is very cool
who knows some some Rogue officer might
have possibly taken one to the front but
if he did we don't know about it
okay I'll stop you there we have another
very heavy machine gun in fact literally
by some definitions laser definitions a
heavy machine gun as in a fixed mounted
machine gun not designed by any means
for carrying and operating by an
individual or Soldier which is what we
see here as as cool as that is when it's
depicted in a movie or in this case a
game it's completely unrealistic and I
won't say no I will say impossible
if you were going to try and heft this
thing and run around with it I don't
think you've had the nice hardwood and
Brass belt box on there I think you just
let the belt out well I don't know would
you the belts are quite long 250 rounds
something like that I don't know you
either have additional weight in bulk or
you have a belt trailing around Rambo
style and you certainly can't held this
one-handed and hold belt with your other
hand so not quite impossible but but not
far off
foreign
French names of course but it was the
American Army's name for this gun so
something it's much more plausible that
you'd be finding and using one of these
multiple Nations have used it it's a
it's an actual light machine gun not not
some ridiculous heavy thing that you
couldn't possibly use in this role
having said that it's still incredibly
heavy and awkward to use and the idea of
using that from the shoulder you know
it's plausible with a brand gun but
something like the Hotchkiss uh it's
it's heavy it's awkward the strip feed
system is extremely awkward as well it's
uh well depicted here I think and of
course that gives us a nice bit of
variety a good trade-off of ammunition
capacity versus a different animation
really we don't really have the weight
penalty of the belt fed guns to worry
about but hey it's variety it's period
it looks good it works well
we have taken objective apples
all right this is I think it's one of my
favorite Battlefield 1 weapons because
it's it fits their their remit so well
in a way that doesn't kind of push
outside my comfort zone if that makes
sense to you in terms of anachronism
this thing existed this is the Italian
cheer regatti the the Cherry regatti is
is well modeled it works basically as
advertised it has a selector switch on
the side something I picked up on
looking at Wikipedia you might remember
the as50 incident well I might have
another one for you guys this trigger
that pokes through the bottom of the
trigger guard people are wondering oh
I've been wondering why on Earth it does
that and the answer given on Wikipedia
is that this is for this is some sort of
Arctic trigger guard so that you can
operate the trigger with with mittens on
if I lock this thing open how do you
close the bolt
there's no bolt catch the answer is
trigger and the reason it pokes through
is that you're not pulling it far enough
back to fire the gun you're just pulling
it far enough back to close the bolt and
then you can get on the trigger proper
and put it all the way through to the
rear
and fire the rifle that is what that
feature is for as far as the internet's
concerned that's an Arctic trigger it
isn't it's the bolt closure device right
so we've just watched a bit of reminding
myself that'll use this a fair bit when
I played the game of how the the bolt is
closed in the game and it is just
manually shoved forward now I understand
why they why they thought that but
that's not how it works
as we now know
this is a strange and rare Beast indeed
we don't have anything like this well
unless you count the shosha a machine
rifle a light machine gun which this is
a relative of potentially only one of
these exists I think I've only ever seen
black and white photos so it's another
classic backfield one weapon in that it
existed in the time frame somebody could
have robbed it from an experimental
facility somewhere and gone to war with
it but they didn't it really does look
cool being so short and submachine gun
like it's called a submachine gun in the
game clearly it isn't in by any
technical definition it finds a a full
power rifle cartridge it takes the
questionable open magazine design of the
show shot machine rifle and makes it
even more questionable by being even
more cut away and exposed to dirt and
whatever else needless to say we have no
idea how how well this would have worked
my guess would be not well
right well they've done it to me again
we've got a a semi-cursed gun it's not
too bad in the scheme of things I could
sort of picture some incredibly
flamboyant Russian officer having some
gold-plated modified 1895 sniper rifle
but only really in a sort of the king's
man-esque retro futuristic setting so I
suppose is what we're in so this thing
is uh it's the rifle of course the 1895
Winchester So like um
most of its Winchester stable mates it's
a lever action
only
the bottom drops out of it I suppose
like other later Winchester's with a
linear bolt coming out the back
[Applause]
now not directly related to the rifle
itself but the it's obviously part of
the kit of the of the sniper and this
idea of a Deployable steel Shield that
you poke your rifle barrel through and
and you have some protection from
incoming fire absolutely correct you
know those really did exist would you
carry them around running and gunning
and set them down knowing full well the
enemy knew where you were absolutely you
would not you would install this
somewhere where the enemy weren't yet or
weren't aware of you yet and use it as a
as a snipers tool or you would have it
on a trench parapet again hopefully
disguised because you don't you don't
want to encourage incoming fire what if
one of those bullets could come through
the loophole in the plate and at the
very least you're drawing fire to your
positions not a great idea to advertise
your position but these things had a
place they were used and they would stop
anything other than I don't know a very
powerful the game rifle or something
depending on their Construction
foreign
next up this is a fascinating one very
unusual looking gun I'm sure you're the
gray nine nine Parabellum is correct now
it's hard for me to assess this because
we don't have one of these they're only
two in existence and one of them's
complete I believe it's the Tula State
University collection but from the
descriptions that I have read it's
pretty well represented except that I
think you would have to shove that
cassette of of cartridges all the way
into the right so that it can then feed
back across to the left and then be
removed when empty that's my reading of
the very complex mechanism of this thing
so as depicted it's an 80 round capacity
uh we end up with the realistic plus one
if we leave around in the chamber and
replace the cassette and that's
comprised of 10 rows of eight cartridges
incredibly complex and frankly
ill-advised mechanism Burns through one
stack of cartridges and then ratchets
the whole thing across by one fires the
next row and so on and so forth there
are there are machine guns that do that
sort of linear feed different thing but
none that do it with vertical strips
that I can think of which makes the
whole gun very tall hence that bizarre
profile and the the arrangement of the
boxing receiver then dictates the
bizarre butt stock and the weird grip
really does look like a fantasy
submachine gun and in a way it's it kind
of is because it was never put into
production it was never used by anyone
it's one of the least plausible guns in
the game in that respect but it's kind
of cool to see it kind of represented
and preserved in digital form
thank you
foreign
I can do it's spelled sjo but uh this is
a Swedish word I'm so sorry sweets um
you speak our language so perfectly and
we don't speak yours at all I feel very
bad about that anyway um fascinating
design so this could easily have been
consigned to the Dustbin of firearms
history but uh made a massive comeback
with well not to be the the Beretta
inertial system totally different gun
but it uses the same principle but
essentially it relies on the on the um
The Recoil of the gun it then stops and
with a two-part bolt with a spring in
between it's able to then unlock itself
using inertia it's so hard to explain
this one but um you'll grasp it like I
did when you watch the animation
all right everyone thank you for
watching those were more guns from
Battlefield one been a while since we
did the first episode I hope you enjoyed
this one as always if you'd like to
check out our own Royal armories YouTube
channel featuring yours truly and some
colleagues as well please do that and we
have our own social media accounts of
course three sites here in the UK that
you can visit if you're able to visit
details of that and events and
everything else on the website thanks
again we'll see you again next time
[Music]
all right